so echo fox is selling their slot in the
LCS riot still has to prove the sale and
Rick Fox is not happy about how things
went down I feel so completely bent over
how is that hell did we get you
[Music]
all right let's start from the beginning
and work our way back to today
back in April Dec ciertos Richard Lewis
reported that Rick Fox was trying to we
Becca Fox because of racist behavior and
threats made by an investor in the
company eventually we found out that
that shareholder was a me try sada who
admitted to using racial slurs in a
conversation with Chase Hall but denied
threatening Rick Fox's family then
screenshots of emails at rosada
allegedly sent a leak showing him
threatening Rick Fox's family surprise
anyway Rick Fox told TMZ that he would
stay with echo fox if Fry's auto left
and then rive stepped in did their own
investigation and said that they'd give
echo Fox 60 days to remove rosanna 542
last week and Wright extended the
deadline one more week now behind the
scenes things weren't going so well
according to Rick Fox speaking on his GG
podcast he and the other members of the
court ownership group of echo Fox spent
in that time searching for someone to
buy the LCS lot without much success
meanwhile the outside investors in echo
Fox who are also co-owners of the
company wanted to sell the org as a
whole not just the LCS lot everything
some of the investors wanted to sell the
whole company others didn't so what we
had to address was one of our assets the
League of Legends slot was in jeopardy
of being taken by Riot because of the
racists development we had an investment
bank we had individuals in the GP
looking to figure out the solution of
that was not having success we reached
our deadline riot gave us an additional
seven days so I find myself with control
and I find myself with a seven-day
window to find somebody to buy the asset
or echo Fox because I had been I was
being pushed and what the people that
were running the process were pushing
for from the some of the limited
partners was a complete sale on Tuesday
about a day after the deadline had
passed right announced that echo Fox was
selling their slot in the LCS
shortly after ESPN's take of wolf
reported that they buyer was Kroenke
sports and entertainment the company
that owns Arsenal the Denver Nuggets the
LA Rams and most importantly to eSports
fans the overwatch leagues la gladiators
and on the podcast Fox confirmed that
report he said he signed the deal on
Tuesday and as it is in fact whiskey
Kroenke group now he didn't confer
the thirty point two five million dollar
price tag but he didn't deny it either
as his co-host on the show including
Jace Hall mentioned it several times
Fox notes that the deal as it stands is
for the LCS slot which a lot of echo
Fox's value is tied up in however the
Kroenke group is quote entertaining the
purchase of echo fox it's unclear if
that full purchase of the orc has
happened or even if it ever will happen
but seemingly those conversations are
going on behind the scenes now before we
get back to Fox in his future in eSports
Riot sent us a statement and there's
some brand new information in here now
we reached out and we got this statement
from Chris Greeley the LCS commissioner
who told us we're working diligently to
minimize disruption to echo Fox players
and staff for the 2019 season in
partnership with the LCS Players
Association
if LCS rejects the proposal echo Fox has
agreed that LCS will be taking over the
sale process for the slot our goal is to
make sure we have an orderly transition
and a new team ready for the 2020 season
now this doesn't give us a lot of new
info but it does reiterate that riot
still has to approve the sale if riot
doesn't approve they'll take over the
sales process and that all this will be
dealt with by the 2020 season there are
a few more statements we received from
really though the first is a pretty
obvious one that riot didn't require fo
Fox to sell their slot but that's how
echo fox chose to comply ride didn't
offer any further comment on an alleged
proposal that's alright saw a trans for
his shares to an entity owned by a
family member of his which is something
that ESPN reported the next thing riot
told us is that they have quote several
areas to discuss with the potential
ownership group including getting an
understanding of their plans around a
team brand
so basically ripe isn't sure what the
new ownership group is gonna do with
regards to keeping the echo fox branding
or making up a new one and finally
Greeley said that Rick Fox is always
welcome at the LCS which is Abe lovely
sentiment but I don't think anybody was
worried about riot not letting him into
the studio to watch sure something but
Rick Fox is not happy about how all this
went down now he's not mad at riot or
the community in fact he doesn't even
say who he's mad at but he is definitely
upset I feel so completely bent over I
feel run over
I feel unappreciated by the entire
group of investors I feel numb I feel
angry I feel attacked
I feel accused I feel unappreciated
I feel unheard I feel angry I feel
disrespected I feel sad I feel confused
I feel blindsided
feel exhausted
exasperated and honestly that's
everything we know right now there are
plenty of questions that go along with
this like who's gonna pay the rest of
the franchise fee how did the value of
an LCS law tripled in the last two years
and what is the Kroenke group gonna do
with the echo fox brand but right now I
feel like the most important question is
what's gonna happen to Rick Fox himself
the League of Legends community is
probably losing Rick Fox is a part of
the LCS there's a chance he sticks
around with a new org I suppose but that
would require the crong Keys to keep him
on as a brand new master or something
and that just seems unlikely I said this
last time we talked about this whole
mess but Rick Fox has been really really
good for eSports it was a shame when it
seemed like you're gonna lose him
because of some racist jerk and it's a
shame when it seems we're gonna lose him
now and Rick Fox doesn't even know his
own future in League of Legends or
eSports which is pretty rough
considering how much of a pillar he's
been for the scene in the last few years
so what are you thinking what's next for
for mr. Fox I can and I I hear your
question and I do not know thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]